ceci est un thomas ceci aussi le
tomahawk c'est vraiment une pièce qui
est brisée en fait pour a créé un espèce
de spectacle
passée une côte de boeuf mais avec un os
qui est gigantesque qui sort un petit
peu le côté cro magnon or chaque année
le chef frédéric dufoix on le voit
depuis quelques années l'engouement pour
cette coupe de viande ne démord pas
c'est vraiment une espèce de trend qui
il ya quand même frénésie la part de la
clientèle qui disent non nous ce qu'on
veut pour être capable de le prendre en
photo avec nos amis de mettre ces
réseaux sociaux au resto attendez vous à
payer au moins 120 dollars pour un
thomas rock à partager
[Musique]
cellcom frappé avec ça maintenant je
sais de juste fils non et si l'on prend
le temps qu'un successeur le boucher
nicolas c'est vrai après paris iii des
coupes différentes à partir de la même
partie du boeuf
qu'est ce que nous avons ici nicolas
alors on a tôt maroc cow boys tech et la
côte de boeuf
techniquement c'est exactement la viande
c'est sûr que pendant la cuisson
on a quelques petites différences le
tomahawk par lui-même en est un aussi
beaucoup plus long cette façon que
pendant la cuisson l'eau si la tendance
à croustiller et le goût diffuse
légèrement dans la viande
ici le taux maroc se vend 49 dollars le
kilo soit 8 $ de plus que la côte de
boeuf une des raisons
la coupe thomas rapide demande plus de
travail pour préparer l' os mais on
s'entend que c'est beaucoup moins cher
que filet mignon est beaucoup plus
coûteux énormément énormément plu
persillé énormément ses demandes
la première fois que j'en ai mangé je me
rappelle la première fois j'en ai fait
fuir tout assez stressé d'avoir une
pièce de viande de ce prix là accueillir
le chef propose une cuisson simple au
barbecue avec comme accompagnement des
pommes de terre de la salicorne et des
chanterelles là on sort au moins une
demi-heure avant de le mettre sur le
barbecue pour éviter un choc thermique
qui va faire que la viande doit vraiment
stressé et puis devenir dur allocution
c'est important de bien assaisonné aussi
je travaille avec celle cacher
l'essentiel qui est un pitbull pleut un
peu plus fin encore plus lent mettre pas
mal ensuite cuisson à peu près 15
minutes de chaque côté bonnes
températures vont commencer on l'entend
sa grille bien à l'effacer mac de
grillage mais tous tendance à fermer ou
paul couvrir ce qui arrive c'est si on
ferme tout de suite on le voit pas puis
la majorité du temps quand on saisit à
haute température ce qui arrive c'est
que leurs gravats se met à couler puis
si on manque d'attention là dessus on va
brûler on connaissait de fer soit
chaleur indirecte ou sur la grille diot
avec une lèchefrite en dessous pour
recueillir le gros ensuite on peut
utiliser ça aussi pour faire qu'une aux
pommes de terre
j'ai fait une trame attisé avec de l'ail
confit du thym du romarin plus la porte
de miso donc on les cherche un petit
côté salé aromatisée avec ça va tout
tomber dans les pommes de terre a dit
pas non
[Musique]
ça sent très bon je trouve toute petite
pièce de viande haut et moins jeunes
entrés est-ce que l'os donne du goût et
la cuisson ou c'est juste pour le show a
fait lorsqu'il soit aussi l'on va c'est
vraiment plus pour le show mais au
niveau de la cuisson cuivre sur ross
j'ai toujours la meilleure chose à faire
parce que lorsque vous regardez une
partie de l'humidité à l'intérieur donc
c'est là qu'on va voir le plus de jus à
l'intérieur de l'audience
le chef conseille de laisser reposer la
pièce de viande 10 à 15 minutes
alors même pas dans l'assiette
[Musique]
tous des finitions avec un peu de fleur
de sel fumé pour aller chercher tout ce
petit côté guerrier fumée le jeu vous la
grèce est vraiment déçu une belle
texture l'humidité en cassant combien
juteux
c'est drôle c'est complètement à
contre-courant ya plus en plus de gens
végétarien végétalien flexitariens plus
on arrive excepté mars pièce de viande
en fait je pense que les gens qui vont
voir le finistère et si ça vient d'un
bon boeuf de belles pièces de viande on
peut réduire notre consommation de boeuf
manger sain il partageait à plusieurs on
est bon pour 4 personnes avec des
accompagnements qui viennent avec aussi
beaucoup le découverte d'un synthé
revendre et puis faut pas oublier une
chose c'est que des légumes one
effectivement les légumes pour manger
les légumes est selon lui sa technique
c'est sûr
parlant de légumes